bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo sullo
speciale 150 mila iscritti sti cazzi
ogni giorno mi viene chiesto che cosa si
prova ad avere così tanti iscritti
perché dunque a 150 mila siti sono una
cosa assurda cioè non avrei mai pensato
di aggiungere traguardi del genere
veramente grazie ragazzi grazie mille
c'è solo il fatto che negli ultimi due
giorni quindi ieri e l'altro ieri
abbiamo totalizzato più di mezzo milioni
di visualizzazioni in due giorni c'è una
cosa impressionante ragazzi io non so
veramente che cosa dire grazie di cuore
veramente siete fantastici
vabbè finiamo alcuni ringraziamenti
perché so che viene un po non è palle
una tiritera che scassa i maroni quindi
direi di iniziare che lo speciale allora
lo sapete già che cos'è perché
mattacchioni avete letto dal titolo se
non esistessero su youtube non ve lo
direi mai che cosa sono gli speciali
però purtroppo devo scriverlo prima di
partire volevo soltanto spiegarvi il
perché ho deciso di fare questo video
come speciale e questa è la risposta va
bene e va a breve a tutti i ragazzi
pervenuti a questa novità
io non sono anche se si spera che lo
capiscano che non sei con i geni e
benvenuti a questo noi di jardel bene
si lavora per i ragazzi benvenuti ad un
nuovo video io non sono fati j
eccoci ad un nuovo
volevo provare a fare sta cosa del verso
si chiamano vecchio abito una funziona
probabilmente io sono justin bieber e
lei dovrebbe essere quella di corni
mediche non mi dica come il nome prova
beh non so come funziona sa cosa del
versus ci provo è una sfida non solo nei
minuti
cos'è tipo tipo street fighter a casa
oppure ma non c'era il fallo ma l'ultima
puntata il mio picchiato
questa così com è
toccanti
vai
bene
[Musica]
c'è
genova
[Musica]
ai
fuori
mister
una cosa
poi è anche poco
[Musica]
ma chi è
pato 6 addetti
[Musica]
ma cosa aspettiamo
facciamo un normale insomma
[Musica]
scusate io
ma scorsa il ministro tu
ma stiamo scherzando
ragazzi io sono geloso di un [ __ ]
ventilatore mai sbattere mignolo sul mio
letto
non sapete nuovo spero di roma ok tutte
il vizio
[Musica]
la casa che prevedendo primo video
no
marco mi stai dicendo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
cosa sono i ragazzi è truccato a sta
cosa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
cos'è sta roba ragazzi ma amiamo
sono venuto a galla
[Applauso]
e lì
[Musica]
si no
io non ho parma nostre parole
beh
loro come fare
ciao
ecco i services e banca non sta
stato
la possiamo fare ragazzi questa sarà la
corsa del secolo sicuro c'è la canzone
del secolo pink altro ordigno
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sì
beh
un cavolo stai a casa ragazzi abruzzo la
situazione andava gioco
[Musica]
ma non pensate male
stata la piccirella
[Musica]
a fine anno
[Applauso]
una busta paga prima di sciogliermi arti
di scioglierci chiuda qui il video
perché non ce la faccio più ragazze mi è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato il
commento mi piace anche la faccia di
facebook e come non divido trovate la
descrizione 67 per iscritti dovrà essere
comando grazie
dammi il braccio e onna vabbè senso per
il synth iscrivetevi e noi ci andiamo in
un prossimo video dai ragazzi